but we're talking about producers like
kind of monetizing their [ __ ] now you
know there's uh people who still do beat
leases and then there's like obviously
like i feel like one of the most like
slept on ways that people find beats and
i know this because we'll have artists
come in and they'll be like yo yo here's
the youtube link it's like these tight
beats on youtube hell yeah every a lot
of upcoming artists and a lot of like
made artists they'll be doing that going
they'll type in their own name type beat
make a bunch of songs you know that [ __ ]
happens a lot we've had so many artists
come in be like i want to do a freestyle
over this but it's uh there's some beat
on youtube and then it'll be like their
own name type beat they'll be like what
the [ __ ] do you even know this guy
they're like nah nah we just [ __ ] with
the beat on youtube i'm like
yeah that's how i started i used to do
tight beats every producer's type b on
youtube walk flock flocka type b slim
dunkin type beats all these type beats
and i used to like drive traction like
when cheeky was hot i do cheap keef type
beat i had a beat i remember how to beat
it was like 250 000 views and [ __ ] like
that's a lot on a b hell yeah you know
so you were kind of like already kind of
doing your thing a little bit
in the producer space yeah like i
remember like they were like the
internet producers and [ __ ] yeah like we
were doing our thing and then i started
like showing like what i looked like and
[ __ ] and i was like oh [ __ ] like who's
this nobody ever would have thought you
looked this way yeah and then like i
feel like that was more like a wow
effect like damn what the [ __ ] he's from
canada like everyone else kind of just
had like their graphic up on their on
their twitter and [ __ ] i was like man i
want to build my face card i want people
to know what i look like you know